では よろしくお願い致します
それから 今日のテーマについて説明したいと思います
今日のテーマは真理の聞き方ということで
真理というのは仏教のブッダのお釈迦様の教えということになります
この場合は で   その聞き方がちょっと伸ばして
普通我々は物事を学ぶ時
どのように聞けばよろしいかということも
時間の範囲で説明したいと思います
まずはこれ イントロダクションで
学ぶってどういうことかと
この前の講演も学ぶことについての説明でしたから
この中のほんの一部ですね
今日は全体的に学ぶってどういうことか説明しました
先月 で 学ぶと学ぶ過程
まあいい言葉 ラーニングアンドプロセスオブラーニングということで
人は学ぶことで成長します
言う必要もないんですね
何か学ばなくてはいけない
人間として生まれたならば
学ぶべきということは
これ絶対的な条件です
わがまま言ってる場合じゃないんです
で 学びたくなければ 人間で生まれて悪かったというしかないんです
時々子供たちもなんか勉強嫌だなと私の前で言っちゃうと
私は何のことなく お前のせいだと
なんで人間で生まれたのかいと
勝手に人間で生まれてね
嫌なのに 私たちとは と
もう猿になった方が犬になった方がよかったよと
っていう風に言った後
子供は何言ってるかよくわからないんだけど
まあとにかく文句言ったらいけないってことぐらいは理解しそうでしょう
で これは私は子供をからかって冗談で言うんだけど
我々は嘘を言わないんです
いつでも冗談で言ったっても
何か事実はその中に隠れているんです
ですから 人間で生まれたならば
学ぶ運命になるんです
それで学ぶ過程っていうのは
仏教心理学的に説明すると
眼耳鼻舌身意というね
我々にはこの感覚器官
知る器官 知る機会が 6つあります
その知る機会  6つに入るデータは6種類ですね
これは色声香味触法というんですね
これはグループネームで
色っていうのは目に入る情報
で 声っていうのは耳に入る情報
で 香っていうのは鼻に
味っていうのは舌に入る情報
触っていうのは体に触れることですね
体から入る情報 法っていうのはもう意識で伝わる情報
それが法と言ってるんですね
法 この場合は仏教の教えではないんです
法ってこの場合は現象ということになるんですね
だから 我々には頭の中でね
過去のことを考えることができる
将来のこともすることもできるしね
もう存在するものも存在しないものも頭で考えることはできるんですよ
とにかく意識の対象になるんですよ
ペガサスのことを考えちゃうと
頭でイメージ作ることはできますよ
存在はしません だから存在するものもしないものも
存在したものとこれから存在するであろうというものも
意識で認識することはできます
これで何かわかるかというと
我々はいつでも現実を認識しているわけじゃないんです
例えば皆様には まあ見たくはないと思いますけど
舞台に立っている私を見るんですね
だから一応現実なんですね
本当は化け物じゃないんです
そう思っている方々がいるならば
その誤解を解いてください
で 目の前にあるスクリーンもこの文字が見えますね
これも現実ですね で 聞こえる場合も音があったら聞こえる
そういうことで 私に見えるだからある
私に聞こえるだからあるという理屈は成り立たないんですよ
ないものも見えるんですよ
鏡で見てください 何か化け物を見るでしょ？あ
間違った 皆様の美しい顔がね
鏡に映って見えるでしょ？で
変でされば皆様の顔じゃなくてあれは逆でしょ？すべて左右曲がってるでしょ
全然気にしないんでしょ
おかしいんじゃないんですかね
全然おかしいと感じたことないと思いますよ
だから鏡で鏡に映る影は自分であると
はっきりくっきりと認めているんですよ
だから私は鏡を見たら化け物見えるだろうと言ったら
なんて失礼な言葉やと思うでしょ
あれはもう結構美しい私の顔だと
違いますけど あれは脳の幻覚なんです
で 幻覚というか まあ視覚なんですけど
もうそれ幻覚なんですね
幻視なんですね といっても
なんか我々はそれがあると思ってるんですよ
そのようにこの 触れたものだったら OK ですね
もう触ってみること そうでもないんです
これは説明するために
古いインドのね 我々の世界ではね
論理学を教えるときは
昔時代の例え出すんですよ
暗闇で歩くと あのロープを踏みます
皆様にはあんまり馴染みないんです
で 皆さんはプラスチックの箱に生活しているんだからね
我々は自然と裸足で自然の中で生活するんですね
だから 足の裏はかなり敏感なんです
足の裏でも結構物事を感じるんです
それで暗闇でロープを踏んじゃった途端
ものすごく怖くなってキャーッと泣くんです
何やらヘビを踏んじゃったと
やばいよと だから脳がヘビを踏んじゃったんだから
身を守れ守りなさいと
もう噛まれたらあんた死ぬぞというすごいデータを作ってるんですね
脳がちゃんとした客観的なデータをもらったんだから
じゃあやってやるぞとプロセッシングしているんですよ
しかし 踏んだのはロープなんです
それは何かと光がなかったんだから確かめることはできなかったんですね
確かめることできなかったところで
余計なデータを作って勝手に補ってしまったんですよ
それでとんでもない結果を出しちゃうんですね
我々に見える蜃気楼も同じなんですね
蜃気楼ないんですよ 脳が幻覚を作るんです
ということで あの意識
の場合は 加工も存在するものもしないものも認識しますが
では五感はどうですかと
で 五感も同じなんですよ
ちょっと信頼できないんです
つい幻覚を作るんです
で 皆様 この香りと味はしっかりしてると思ってるでしょ？結構私は日本人をそこまで実験したことがあるんです
で ちょっと脳の思考を変えちゃうと
まあ辛いものは辛くないと思ったり
辛いのに辛くないと思ったり
いろいろです で 皆様は辛いものは辛いに決まってるだろうと思ってるでしょ？でもちょっと思考をちょっと変えればね
辛いなのに辛くないと認識する
ある人は私にもうちょっと辛くしてくれませんかと頼んだんですけど
あれは私にも食べられないくらい辛く作ったんです
わざと で しかし この人は辛いものを食べられない体質やと知っていて
では認識をね ちょっと変えればいいんじゃないかと
そこでまあちょっとした言葉で辛くないと認識するようにと言ったんだから
そちらの方が私が言ってる通り認識するんです
だからなんかそこを見るとなんか自分の心なり
人の勝手に認識するとは何ぞやと
そんなもんなんですよ
相当大変ですよ この人に
あの いろいろ 人の影響を受けないで
人の影響によって自分の認識がごちゃごちゃにならないように認識過程を守るということはね
大変な訓練が必要なんです
で またある人々はわざと幻覚が現実やと思ってね
とことん幻覚ばっかり作ったりして
幻覚 幻聴などなどをね
これで脳が壊れるんですね
そういう人々を助けることは
もういくらなんでも まあ私たちは一応心理学だからね
仏教だからね そこら辺プロなんですけど
もうできないんですね
それで まあ機能壊れたらね
車の 例えばもう車輪が壊れて
もう破れて出て行っちゃったら
いくら修理屋さん来てもこの車動かせないんですよ
とにかく脳を壊さないで守ってほしいんです
はい それで あの仏教は心理学的に理解しやすくするために
そういうカテゴリーネームを作って
あの眼耳鼻舌身意とね
それは別にこのままなんですね
意っていうのは 仏教は脳細胞はあまり使わないんですね
肉体のことは医者に任せちゃって
心だけの働きは仏教の管轄で
ですから 目といったっても肉眼ということじゃないんです
仏教では肉眼持っている感受性
センシティビティ 感受性が仏教で眼というんですね
肉眼はもう医者の世界
ただのカメラですからね
そちら問題だったら 医者に医者に頼んで治ってもらいもらいなさいと
しかし 医者にできないのはこの感受性なんですね
これはもうどうすることもできないんですね
感じる目で何か何かをね
そこは仏教で他の場合でも同じ
耳鼻舌身意の場合でも同じことで
で 現代ではこの脳細胞が考えているんだぞと言うんだけど
仏教はそう言わないんですね
まあ何か肉体があるかもしれませんだけど
この感受性なんですね
ですから そこは心としている
意っていうのは心のことなんですね
これ日本語でいいと言うんですけど
ロープウェイのサンニャサンカーじゃなくて
着想とかの字が代わりにマナなんですね
で マナっていうのは認識する威勢の状態
いいという感じでよろしい
今思い出したんだけど
これでよろしいかどうかね
有識仏教ではマナ識という言葉を使ってますからね
そのカタカナのマナ使うしかないやと思いますけど
はい ス記で書いているのは
学ぶとは なんでしょうかと
これで我々にはデータを受ける受ける感受性
6種類がありますね 感じること
それで 6種類のデータを感じるんですね
感じたものを認識しないんですよ
いつだって幻覚したり
捏造したり 概念作ったり
勝手なんですね だから目があるんだからといって事実を見えるわけじゃないんです
耳があるんだからって
本当のことを聞いているわけじゃないんです
他の感覚器官があったとしても
結局は自分自分が勝手に勝手なものを考えたりするんですね
だからそれを言ったら
我々は知識にものすごい価値を入れているんです
自分の考えにものすごい価値を入れてるんです
これ 私の考えでしょうと
考えるのは自由でしょうと
考えることは自由じゃないんです
ただ考えることは暴走しているだけ
考えることも因縁によって考えているんです
しかし 因縁によって足すべき答えに達しないんです
雷が落ちたら怖いと怯えちゃう
それ余計です 大きい音が来たかもしれませんし
ものすごい光ったかもしれませんし
それで終わっちゃうんだけど
しかし 私たちはもうちょっと進んで幻覚を作るんですね
だから世の中にある知識などなどっていうのは
それから私たち知識 知識だと思っているものっていうのはね
私の考えとかね もうほとんどもう生ゴミみたいな感じで
そんな大した価値がないんだと
と思った方が楽ですよ
ものすごい生きること楽なんです
どうせ私の思考だから
ろくでもないものだと
こんなのは当てにならんやと
その人その人好き勝手なことを考えているんだからと
いうふうに思った方が楽だなと思います
はい それで学ぶという場合は
１ 思考能力  ２ 判断能力の成長と
３ 人格向上することです
で 学んだということは
このごちゃごちゃ考えたではなくて
思考能力をね 今はこんなもんだからね
もうロープを踏んじゃったらもうヘビやと驚く世界にいるんだから
鏡に映るのは自分やと思ってるんだからね
もうちょっと で 思考能力どんどん上げなくてはいけないんですね
まあ人間はね 文明と一緒にね
まあ一応思考能力はまあ上げて上げては向上させて
進捗成長させてはいますが
いまだにまあそんなに驚くほどの進歩
進歩はないんです いまだに人間が証拠のないものは信じない
という原始人の弱み そのまま持っているんです
調べる方法ないものは簡単に信じる
信じるというか 自分好みで信じるんです
で 判断能力っていうのはね
最初はないんですね 赤ちゃんには
それでどんどん判断能力が上がっていくんですね
これはもう徹底的に正しい判断できるところまで成長させなくてはいけないんです
で  3番目はこの人格向上
で 形だけで人間に生まれるんだけど
本格的な文字通りの人間になるためには
まあ相当勉強しなくちゃいけないんですよ
生まれたら人間ではないんです
学んだら人間なんです
そこはちょっと使いづらいだから
お釈迦様はまあ人間という言葉を
そのまま世間の言葉だから使って学んだら超人になりますよと
うっかりマヌッサになりますよと
学ばない人々はマヌッサである
しかし パーリのパーリ語ではこの同義語を使うんだから
時々マガという言葉も人間に使うんですね
マガっていうのは獣っていう言葉なんですけど
でも人間にも使う これはパーリ語でちょっと古い単語なんですけど
で 古い経典 古い層に入る経典ではマガという言葉もあります
マガっていうのは 普通サンスクリット語で普通パーリ語でマガミガミガマっていう発音をしますね
サンスクリット語でミガミガなんですね
ミガだからパーリ語になるとミガになりますし
ルという発音難しいところですけど
リというね それも母音ですけどね
ミガ で それが落としてマガとも言うんですね
で 人間にも使えます しかし
一般パーリ語では 人間は学んだら超人になりますと
いわゆる人間を超えてすごい立派なものになりますというふうに言ってますね
学ぶ時の優先的なチャンネルは聞くことと見ることです
あれ  6つ説明しましたけど
我々はだいたい聞いてみて
たくさん大量なことを学ぶんです
味でたくさん学べませんよ
触ることでもそんなたくさんのことを学べないんです
鼻で嗅いでみて 匂い嗅いで
何も学べませんね いい匂いか悪い匂いか
それで終わっちゃうんです
しかし 匂いの世界も結構広い世界ですよ
犬の言語は全部匂い語になってますからね
犬は匂いで区別するんです
で 普通ないのはね それで今病院ででも香りっていうのはね
直接脳に行くんだと だったらこの落ち着いて気持ちを穏やかにして
このアルツハイマーとかね
認知症もいろいろ種類ありますから
あの そういう認知症でね
悩んでいる方々の苦しみ
和らげる方法はないのかとね
で 研究したりして それから眠れないとかね
それも脳の問題なんですね
で そうなってくると その適切な香りを鼻に入るようにすると
脳が脳にそれ入って 脳がすごく落ち着いて
まあ寝るというね いわゆる
それは一般女性の間ではアロマアロマと言いながらね
よく使っていたんです
あれは欲ばっかしでね
まあもういい切りなり戦っていただけなんですけど
今 女性たちの間で人気だったアロマ世界が
一応科学者の医者の手に入っちゃって
まあそれはちゃんとアロマテラピーというね
まあ薬ではない方法でも治療できるんではないかなとね
と思ったりする ですから
科学世界も私たちは思ったほど単純じゃないんです
ただ調べて学んでないだけで
そこで私がいい気持ちになります
この香りは穏やかな気持ちになったんだそうと言ったら
それは私のことで 私はそれ実験しなくちゃいけないんですね
他の人々は どう感じるのかと
で 私の体の場合は この西洋薬よりはアユールヴェーダ薬はものすごく効くんです
しかし 残念ながら今の今はもうそうやって病気を調べて治療することはほとんどアユールヴェーダ医者がやらなくて
決まっている薬をあげてそれで終わりっていうことにしちゃうんですね
面倒くさいやと 昔そうじゃなくて
ちゃんと下薬調合してくれましたけど
最近になって なんで私がその薬で治るのかい？と思ったら
このアユールヴェーダ薬っていうのは
薬草の匂いがものすごいんですね
だから私はこの匂いでわかるんです
この薬効くか効かないかと
それで風邪ひいたら ５
つその薬草煎じて私は飲むんです
最近頭が悪くて風邪引かないんだけど
前は結構風邪引きましたからね
で 西洋薬は全然効かないし
この細菌体から出ていくまで待たなくちゃいけない
あの薬草を煎じると このすごく香りがね
部屋中飛んでいくんですね
あれでものすごくいい気分になっちゃって
鼻からなんとすごく軽くなっちゃって
ということは おそらく脳にかなり影響を与えるとは思いますね
脳に影響を与えて 脳が活発になっちゃって
まあ気持ち悪いところはなんとかなんとか治療されているのではないかなと
まあ余計な話で そこは止まります
で 言いたいポイントは
この私たちの場合は この鼻とか舌
ベロとかはなくて 目と耳が学ぶときすごい仕事しているんです
その中でも聞くことは強力です
では 目から学びますか？耳から学びますか？たくさん
より深く たくさん要領はどこから学びますかというと
目ではないんです 耳です
これ面白いんですよ なんか私たちは目だろうと思ってるんですよ
目ではないんです だって皆様本読めないでしょ
目がなかったら だから目でしょう
目じゃないんです 本当は脳の中に本を読むとか
何が起こると思っている？脳が喋っているんです
音なんです 本に何もないんです
ただのシンボルだけ シンボル見たら脳が音を作るんです
だからこれ見たってもね
この学ぶというね これは別にただの絵で見ただけで
頭の中で学ぶという音が現れるんですよ
だから本を読む 現代は本がありますからいいんだけど
本を読んで勉強する時でも
結局脳は聴覚チャネルを使っているんです
あれは聴覚チャンネルのデータなんです
例えばね 漫画本より活字本はたくさんのデータを与えます
皆様は漫画本好きですけど
私は漫画わからないんですね
だから読まない で カートゥーンというものは読みますね
それはまあ 1コマで 2コマで何かストーリー持ってくるんですけど
でもそんなたくさんデータ伝えることできません
絵で語るっていうのはね
難しいんですよ 相当なプロでないと描けないんですね
描いたっても もう何時間も苦労して描いて
そんなもんかいってことになっちゃうんです
だから この漫画中毒になっていることで
思考能力は結構低下していると思います
ある子供が私と喧嘩しちゃったんですけど
その子はね もう活字は嫌やと
このややこしい文字で書けなくても
もう絵で描けばそれで十分でしょうと
すぐわかるでしょうにと
その方が早いんだと しかし
私はその子に質問したのは
いえ 絵で見るとあなたの頭がロックされますよと
バカになりますよと という言葉使ったんですね
かえって子供ですからね
頭が硬くなってロックになっちゃってバカになりますよと
それで例え出したんで
例えば あの子供がドカンと水たまりに飛んだとしましょう
それで漫画で描けば水たまりがあって
子供はそれで飛ぶ それから水がチャーッと飛び上がることになりますと
それは言葉で読んでみてくださいと
何々君がもう雨が降っている時
こういうもうこういう風に歩いていて
水たまりがありまして
そこでドカンと飛びましたと
そこで体中ズボンやらシャツやら全部びしょぬれになっちゃったと
それであなたにどれぐらいイメージ作れますか？と
道路を歩いていると書いたところで
読む読む人は別々な道路をイメージするんだと
これ何々君とイメージはそれぞれ人が自分勝手な子供のイメージを作るんだよと
そこで体びしょぬれになったことも
それぞれの人は自由にイメージを作るんだよと
これ漫画で描いちゃうと何一つも起きませんよと
あのひとりの人間が考えた妄想でストップされますよ
ロックされますよ だからバカになりたければ
あんた漫画どんどん読めと
頭が良い人間になりたければ
それ全て難しくても本読めと
本を読むと頭がずっと仕事をしなくちゃあかんですね
心は入るデータに頼って思考して判断する
それで心はどうするのかって
心というのはいのことですね
マナのことですね この入る入るデータをデータに頼って思考する
判断する それによって性格が変わっていく
それで性格も変わっていきます
だいたいそういうのは流れでセットでほぼ起こるんです
学ぶ時のコマンドコントロールは思考組織の管轄ですね
コマンドコントロールというのは中央司令官ということでね
すべて管理するのは思考組織ですね
思考をすることもある
ある過程で思考するんです
だからこの組織と書いたんです
システムと で アビダンマを仏教アビダンマ読んでいるならばわかるだろうと思いますけど
まあ思考というのは 思考にはそれなりのプロセスがあります
そこで思考するプロセスがすべて指令出すんです
ということは コマンドコントロールだから中央司令部だからね
思考は 相当気をつけなくちゃあかんですよ
思考に対しては これもう我々の運命
命すべてかかっているんです
思考の仕方で運命が決めるんです
決まるんです どのような人間に成長するのかは思考次第なので
客観的に論理的にデータに基づいて思考する方法を優先的に学んだ方が良い
この思考の自由ややら
そんなもうなんて言いますか
いい加減なことを言って遊んでいる場合じゃないんですよ
思考によってすべて決めてしまいます
どんな人間として成長するのか
どんな人間になるのか
人生は成功するのか 失敗するのか
幸福になるのか 不幸になるのか
地獄に落ちるのか 解脱に達するのかどうかね
何から何まで思考によりなんです
結婚したら幸せな結婚生活になるか
喧嘩ばっかりしちゃって途中で中止になるのかと
これは戦争の怨念じゃないんです
思考なんです 神の怒り買ったわけじゃないんです
思考です あの 例えば文字がきれいかきれいかないかとかね
それは手で手の訓練だと普通は思ってるんですね
たくさん書けば美しい文字は書けるだろうと
たくさん訓練しても書けないんです
思考を変えないと で 私はもうスリランカでは有名です
最悪なんです 文字はものすごい汚いんです
自分でも気持ち悪い 他人のところじゃないんです
だから小さい時からもう手では書きませんよと思って
いつでももう機械に頼って書く
で しかし なんで私にどこに問題あるのかというと
これ直す方法ありますよ
今でも直せようと思ったら直せます
問題は手にあるんじゃないんです
思考にあるんです だから美しい文字を書きたい人がます書く前に書く能力ない
それほど上手に書けない人はやるべきことは
まず頭の中で美しい字をね
頭で描くんです 頭でどれほど鮮明に描けるのかっていうことが問題ですけど
とにかく頭の中で鮮明に字を書いて描いて作るんです
それから手でその絵を擦ると言うんですか
擦っちゃえばいいんです
なする なすっちゃえ なぞっちゃえばいいんです
もう綺麗な字になっているんです
そこで頭でイメージする場合は
大体かっこ悪い字はイメージにならないんです
どうしても自分にかっこ悪い字が浮かぶんだったら
誰かのね もうサンプルのモデルになる字を見て
そこをイメージすればいいんです
はい 私もそういう風にちょっと字を見て
あっ これは書けそう だってあまり頭にイメージしようと思わないんですね
目で見れば十分だと それ十分じゃないんです
そこで私はいつでも失敗して失望して
まあやめちゃったということでやめるんです
だから 思考が問題ですよ
いつだって このイメージを作ることも思考の結果なんですよ
思考って必ず言語ってわけじゃないんです
そこで右利きの人が左手で書きたくなっちゃうと
皆様の漢字はそんなに大きい問題じゃないんだけど
我々の文字は左右であるんだからね
だって人との人という字はね
鏡で見たって読めるでしょ
入りには読めないでしょ
それ読める 例えば口という字は鏡で見たら窓にならないでしょ
口です しかし 左右上とある文字はそうじゃないんですよ
読めないんです 同時に書けないんですよ
でも訓練しないで書ける方法あります
まず書きたい字を頭でイメージ作る
作って 頭で左手を使ってなぞる
その字をなぞるんです
左手で手は使わない 頭で左手でうーん
と書いて書くんです それで左手で書けます
そういうことで まあいろんなからくりありますよ
この脳の働き 心の働きを知っておくと
いろいろ面白い遊びできます
もう左手で書くっていうことは
一応私もやってみたんですね
書けるんですよ 先に頭でイメージ作っちゃうと
それで頭にイメージ作らないで書く場合は
すごくもう右手で書くのも自分も気持ち悪いほどかっこ悪いでしょ
左手で書いたらもう話にならないんです
しかし まず頭で書いてから書くと
右手書いたと同じ状態になるんです
はい そういうことで この例えばこの有名な優秀な書道家の方々の場合は
字は頭にあるんですよ
いつでも 頭にも作品あるんです
いつでも頭にある作品
サッと瞬間で墨で見せるだけ
紙を見てどう書こうかな
どこからそう思ってないんです
何も思ってないんです
頭の中に作品ができちゃうんです
できているんですね それは紙に移すんです
それは一番優秀な人を
人はそうするんですね
訓練して 訓練して 修行して
修行して しっかり頭で全てできるようにするんです
画家も同じなんですよ
もうかなりの優秀な画家っていうのは
絵は頭にあるんです 先に
それから紙に何か塗って
絵の具塗って表現するだけ
それはそんなに大したことじゃないんです
はい そういう俗世間の例から見ても
思考がすべて コマンドコントロール
中央司令部 思考の仕方に問題があるならば
何を学んでも人の役に立たないんですよ
だから思考に問題があるんだったら役に立ちません
何学んでも 知識を得ること
思考方法を習うこと 人格が向上することは
心の中でほぼ同時に起こるんです
ほぼ同時なんです 同時ではないんです
ほとんど同時に起こるんです
ということは 知識を得る
知識を得るとは 判断能力もしている
判断能力できたとは 思考能力もいくらか増しになっているということは
人間としてもいくらか成長している
だからいっぺんに起きます
そんなに困らなくても
なんでほぼという言葉を使ったかというと
時々我々は心に影響を与えないでいろんなものを学ぶ場合もあります
で まあちょっと面白くないんで
ちょっと新聞を開けてちょこちょこと読んだとかね
まああんまり影響を与え
それで人格が変わるとか
何のこともなくすぐ忘れちゃう
まあそういうことも結構ありますね
まあただまあ読んでみただけでとかね
はい 次のセクション 知識のハンディというものあるんです
これは持って生まれるんです
かわいそうで 知識があればね
思考能力があれば最高に幸福になるのに
ハンディを持って生まれるんです
だからそう簡単に幸福にならないんです
人は感情の衝動で生きるというハンディを持って生まれるんです
人だけじゃなくて どんな生命も生きる衝動は感情なんです
思考じゃないんです だから感情にいじられて思考するんです
だから動物は思考しないんですね
おそらく しないっていうのは間違いですけど
まあ相当思考はするんだけど
まあ人間ほどのくだらない思考はしないしね
まあ思考しなくても生きられます
感情があるんだから 動物にある感情というのは
基本的に恐怖感と存在欲で怒りもあるし
まあ人間も同じ感情ですね
この感情で生きることが我々のハンディなんですね
障害なんです 要するに
生命とはみんな認知障害なんでしょう
一部の人々をなんか病気だな
かわいそうだなと思うなことあっても
我々もみんな結局は認知障害なんです
で 知識を得る場合 障害になる
そのハンディ この感情はね
知識を得る場合は障害になる
思考が乱れて 間違った方向へ流れて
間違った判断し 判断と間違った生き方をする結果になります
これが結果なんです すべて間違いなんです
だから覚えておきましょう
感情の衝動は 我々にとっては知識障害になるんだと
そこで間違った思考を乱れる
思考が乱れたら もう皆さんも知ってるでしょ？怒ったら思考が乱れるでしょ？欲がこみ上げてきたらもう思考は乱れるでしょ
恥ずかしいことになったら
ものすごく思考が乱れるでしょ
感情ですね 興奮したら
怖くなったら すぐ乱れてしまいます
これって最悪なんですよ
思考が乱れたら判断が間違ってる
判断が間違ったら行動が間違ってる
行動間違ったら結果が間違ってる
最悪になるんです 降伏して持って生まれたハンディを乗り越えなくてはならないんです
これが仏教が世に教えるすごくものすごいありがたい宝物なんですね
このハンディを持って生まれるんだよと
ですから 偉そうなあれやこれやと学ぶ前に
このなんとかこのハンディを克服しなくちゃいかんですね
ハンディを克服しながら学んでいくんです
だからたくさん仏教仏典とあるのはそのためなんですよ
まず 例えば戒律を守りなさいということも
このハンディを降伏してほしいんですよ
感情がこみ上げてこないようにするんです
ものすごい大量に そのために仏典がね
大量にデータ使って経典があって喋ってるんです
はい これで一つあの チャプターが終わりましたけど
次のセクションに入ります
そのセクションに入る前にちょっと説明します
例えば 感情で本を読むと
自分がある一種類の本しか選べないんですよ
例えば小説ありますね
で 冒険的な小説やら もうなんかもう男女のもう愛
恋をばっかり書いている
私は読まない すごい気持ち悪くなるんですね
で 小説やらね 時々別なテーマの小説と感じよってると
もうそういうチャプターが来ると飛ばしちゃうんです
面倒くさい もう時間もったいないと
何もないんですね 内容は
それから何て言いますか
このいろいろ もう探検でしたっけね
ハードボイルドとかね
いろいろそういうもう系のね
小説もあるでしょ いろんなもの
歴史的なものもあるしね
それで自分の何か好みがあったら
自分がその系統の本しか読まないでしょ
それで世の中の小説と作品について知ることにならないんですね
結局は だから感情っていうのはそんなもんで
まああんまり役に立たない
はい 次のチャプターに行きます
仏教は聞いて実践して学ぶ世界ですね
だから宗教ということではないんですね
聞いて実践して学んでいく
聞くことも学び 実践することも学ぶです
踊り 歌 音楽 祭り 儀式 儀礼
禅礼 伝授 秘伝 イニシエーションなどは基本的に仏教ではありません
お釈迦様は全くないんです
宗教として退化していく過程で変えてしまったんです
まあ仏教にも踊りあるは
音楽あるは何でもありますよ
儀式 儀礼もあるわ あれはブッダの教えではなくて
仏教なんですね ブッダの教えが退化したんですね
宗教として それでまあ
時代の流れとともに退化していって
これは大乗仏教だけじゃなくてね
テーラワーダ仏教と今言ってるものも
長い歴史の中で退化しているんです
だから退化した仏教は宗教なんですね
儀式儀礼で終わっちゃうんです
まあそれも嫌な人のことは超気持ち悪くなりますけどもね
だから私は一応お釈迦様の教えはどういうものかということを紹介している仕事をやってます
はい 今日のテーマの元になった経典
これから読んでみましょう
聞き方を教える経典 テーラワーダですね
ヤサダって尊者の言葉なんですね
まあパンチャカニパータナ 10番目の経典です
ウパーランバチットードゥンメドーソナアティジナサーサナーン
アーラカーオーティサッダンマーナヴァッソーパタヴィヤターという
無知な人が非難する目的でブッダの教えを聞いても
真理正法から遠ざかるのです
大地と空のように まあ歌ですからね
で こちら この非難する目的という言葉をね
大事なんですね それでパーリ語ではこのウパーランバ
こちらですね で 非難する目的で仏教を学んでも
その人は学んでも学ん
真理学んでも学んでも
真理から遠く遠く遠く行ってしまっちゃうんです
すごく離れてしまいます
これをたとえで天と地のようにと
このウパーランバチットーっていうのは
この辞書で非難っていう風になりましたけど
英語で言えばこのアグレッシブアプローチなんですね
アグレッシブな気持ちで学ぶと
えーと 偈ですからね 一回だけでも節入れなくちゃ
ウパーランバチットードゥンメドーソナアティジナサーサナーン
パリハーヤティサッダンマーカーレパッケーヴァチャンディマー
ほとんど似ていますね
無知な人が非難する目的でブッダの教えを聞いても
真理から衰退する 真理から真理の中で空かどうか分からないんですけど
真理の中でどんどんどんどん成長するんじゃなくて
衰退して衰退して消えてしまいます
学んでも学んでも消えてしまいます
例えば これはどうやって読みますか？懺
この読み方  懺言  懺言 懺言の月のように
言葉合ってるかどうか分かりませんだけども
すごい苦しき自称 です
いろいろ辞書をね それであのワクチンなんて英語で言えばね
月には 2つありますね
どんどん大きくなる  15日間多くなっちゃって
それからウェーンというのは 15日間どんどんどん消えて新月になってしまうというところ
こちらはこの満月からもう新月になる減る半
それは斬言というんですね
だから非難する目的で仏教を学ぶと
あなた斬言の月と同じだとどんどんどんどんもう消えて消えてきますよと
それで面白いことは 学べば成長するはずですけど
決まってるんです それでも逆結果も出てきます
ウパールンバチットドゥンメードスナアティヴィチナサーサナン
パリスッサティサッダンメマッジョアッポードケヤタ
無知な人が非難する目的でブッダの教えを聞いても
真理正法は乾燥しますと
で乾燥すると この若人が乾燥したらありがたいんだけど
それじゃなくて この例えを見てください
わずかな水の中に住む魚のように
だから魚には水が必要でしょうし
だから真理は水のように健康で幸せで生活するべきのは魚でしょう
これもう非難の目的持っちゃうと
水がどんどん乾燥していくんです
って結果は最後にわかる切った結果になります
次のゲイ ウパールンバチットドゥンメードスナアティジナサーサナンナヴィルーハティサッダンメケッテビージャンワプーティカン
無知な人が非難する目的でブッダの教えを聞いても
真理正法は成長しません
畑に腐った種をまいたように
畑は立派ですけど まく種は腐ってるんです
意味がないんですね はい
これ最後 ヨートゥットチッテーナスナアティジナサーサナンケペッンワーセーサンデサッチカッワクッパタング
パップイアパラマンサンティンパリニンブパリニンバータニワニニパリニンバーティナアサオー
もし人が喜びの心でブッダの教えを聞くならば
一切の煩悩を捨てて ゆらがない境地を経験し
究極の安穏に達するであろう
煩悩を滅尽して涅槃に達するのですと
たったワンポイントですよ
このアグレッシブでブッダの話を聞くか
喜びの心で聞くかなんです
アグレッシブで聞いちゃうと
あの 何でしたっけ？どんどんと遠ざかっちゃうんです
水たまりに住んでいる魚のように
水たまりがもう乾燥してしまいます
はい そういうことで 真理はどのように聞くべきかということで
たった一行で答えますけど
トッタチッテーナ 喜びの心で
こんなあたりですね 喜びの心
どこ行ったっけ なんか間違った
で  この喜びの心で まあここら辺ですね
はい ではこのウパールンバっていう言葉をちょっと守りましょうか
この実らない聞き方っていうのはウパールンバですね
ウパールンバは辞書で非難と訳されています
しかし 意味は張り合う気持ち
喧嘩する気持ち 破壊する気持ち
軽視する気持ち あら探し気持ち
対立する気持ちです 結構複雑です
ウパールンバっていう言葉の意味は
非難と言えばあまりにも単純な意味ですよ
だからこの今 私が動議をたくさん
日本語の同義語をたくさん使ってます
使いましたから そこ合わせた意味なんですね
なんか対立的な態度 なんか反抗的な態度
まあ普通日本語でいう反抗的な態度なんですね
ウパールンバっていうのは
否定して壊すというバイアスを持って学ぶという意味なんですね
反抗的で学んでも もう学べないんですね
心がもうもう攻撃態勢になっているんですね
データに対して 受け入れる体制じゃないんですね
だから学べないんですね
世の中のことを学ぶとき
よく見られるパターンです
だいたい世の中ででも
我々は結構反抗的な態度をとるんですね
反抗的な態度をとったら終わり
その学べないんです 例えば大学であろうが
学校であろうが 先生に対して反抗的な態度を持たれたら
もうそれでその人の将来性は終わり
どうでも 例えばもうもう最悪の先生だとします
先生はもう最悪 もうまくに
これは事実 それでも生徒が反抗的な態度をすると学べないんです
これは心理学的なことなんです
教えて かつて教えていただいたものも
どんどん自分から落ちてしまいます
だから人はどうかどうでしょうかっていう話じゃないんです
ここで私が言いたいのは
学ぶのは自分なんです
自分の心の内は反抗的というところがあったら
張り合う気持ちがあったら
あら捜しの気持ちがあったら
もうデータが入らない
成長 成長しない 知識が入りません
判断能力は育ちません
人格は向上しません あの心
懺悔 何でしたっけ？月のようにもう減ってしまいます
はい 次の言葉は正しい言葉はトゥッタティテーナ
喜びの心 喜びの心で真理を聞くならば
人格が成長して 煩悩が滅尽して解脱に達します
これは究極な結果 即席の結果は言うまでもないんです
頭が良くなっちゃって
よく勉強できちゃって
もう優遇優等生で合格できたりとか
そんなのはもういたって簡単
解脱にまで達する では
トゥッタティテーナとはどのような心でしょうか
と これ学ばないと 喜んで聞いて大丈夫ですか？と
何でもかんでも喜んで聞いたらいいんですかね
これ問題あります 好きなもの
自分の考えに合ったものを聞くときも
人が喜びを感じます 自分好きなものを学ぶと
好きなことを聞くと 好きな本を読むと楽しいんですよ
じゃあブッダが教えた喜びですかね
あれは これは それにハマると成長も新たなことを学ぶこともできなくなります
だからこれじゃないんですよ
好きな本を読んで学ぶことじゃないんです
しかし 好きな本を読むと楽しい
喜びの心が生まれます
が これが結構落とし穴なんです
そうすると ある偏見的な一部しか学べないんです
思考も偏見になります
狭くなります 成長ができなくなります
ウパーランバっていうのは怒りです
ウパーランバがあったら何も学べない
好みは欲です 既存の知識は増えるが
新たな知識 新たな発見
大胆な成長はできません
好みでやっちゃうと 自分すでに持っている知識はちょこちょこっと伸びます
それだけ 新たなものは入らないんです
いわゆる大胆な成長はないんです
そういうことで うかつに喜ぶんじゃないんです
好みで説法を聞く場合
よく仏教を我々経験するものなんですけどね
好みで仏教を聞く場合は
欲のバイアスが入ります
これ 我々説法する人々にある一つの運命的な悩みですけど
あの説法を聞きたいんだから
仏教を学びたいんだから教えてよ
教えてよと偉そうなことを言う人はいくらでもいるんです
よくよく見ると その人々は自分の欲でこれこれ知りたいと
時々キリスト教の方々はキリスト教の牧師さん
神父さんと腹立てて喧嘩をしていて
あんた仏教を教えてくれと
教えてあげませんだけどね
その場合は あいつは悪人だと
私 そうでそうと言ったら乗ってくれますけど
それは学ぶ世界じゃないんですね
そこで仏教の場合 私は仏教大好きですよとかね
言ってはくるんだけど
私たちは一応ちょっと心の中を調べると
この人はこういうこういうところで欲を抱いて
この自分の欲を正当化するもの
聞きたいんですね そこでブッダの教えを教えてあげると
自分の欲を正当化 正当化するところまで聞いて
次に人格のところに行ってくると腹立て出ていくんです
あるところで私はもう基本的に仏教を始めて
長い間教えて教えて まあ基本的に学ぶべきことは道徳的なことやら基本的なことをそれは喜んで
私たちはそれは昔から興味ありましたとかね
まあ私もその通りやと思ってる
調子に乗らないと気持ちやりますけどね
そんな程度でわかるわけじゃないし
そこで私は じゃあこれで次は人格のところに入らなくちゃいけないんだと
言って それに関わる経典を一つ
二つ選んだんです 一つの経典は徹底的に分析して教えたんですけど
じゃあ次この経典に行きましょうと
準備してくださいと言ったら
これから来ないでくださいということになったんです
だから あれ 欲で聞いていたんですね
好みで だから 何の仏教からも偉大なる影響は受けなかったんです
自分の性格を肯定する話を集中して聞きますが
しつけに関することを教えると機嫌が悪くなって
怒りがこみ上げて教えを否定するんです
これはよくある話で 知りたくて興味を持って仏教を学び始めたが
途中で怒りを抱いて仏教を非難することになるケースもよくあります
そのケースもありますよ
初めは何か知りたくて学ぶんだけど
ある日突然仏教を非難する人になっちゃうんです
あれ インターネットで私に悪口を言う人々も
大体最初は何か何か学びに来たんです
だから言葉を読んだり
思考を読んだりすると
なんとなくあの野郎じゃないか
この野郎じゃないかという推測
妄想もないわけじゃないんです
だから自分が頑固で自分を変えたくはないんですよ
それで仏教は非難 侮辱
侮辱したってもね 自分が破壊するだけだからね
バイアスが割り込むと客観性はありません
というかなくなります
欲 怒りだけではなく 嫉妬
傲慢 落ち込み 怠け 無知などのすべての感情が心のバイアスになります
これが大事なポイントなんです
これがハンディなんですね
感情が 心に感情を割り込むことは
学ぶことのハンディなんです
このハンディがバイアスになるんですね
わかりやすいバイアスは怒りと欲なんです
しかし 嫉妬で学ぶ場合もバイアスなんです
傲慢で学ぶ場合もバイアスなんです
見栄で学ぶ場合もバイアスなんです
私は教えると言って教えていた時代でも
生徒の中でどうも成長しない
何人かがいるんですね
すごく嫌なんですね 全く成長しない
で 見たらこの見栄があるんですね
だからかわいそうで ちゃんと宿題もするわ
一生懸命本を何回何回何回読み直したりもするわ
高い点数取る取る生徒たちよりも
時間的に言えば 3倍4倍ぐらい頑張ってるんですけど
点数は全然合格点に来ないんです
だから直そうとするんだけど
直せないんですね どうしても自分が自分のこの見栄を捨てないんです
人は感情で生きるから
誰にでも正しく学ぶことはできなくなっています
だから人は感情で生きているんだから
正しく学ぶということは誰にもできないと言って諦めるのではなくて
このバイアスを このハンディを克服するんです
それのキーワードはパサンナチットなんですね
喜びの心 それで喜びは欲ではありませんと言いましたね
それからそれは説明していきます
心の働きを精密に分析して理解しましょう
この正しい喜びっていうのは
わかりやすく言えばキュリオシティなんですね
まあ日本訳は興味なんですね
どちらの方が意味がいいかわからないんだけど
まあこれレベルありますからね
なんか何かなんか知りたくてウズウズしていることは
英語ではキュリオスというんですね
まあ皆さんはあんた興味ある
興味あると聞くでしょ
だから興味あるのは感情だったら欲の興味か怒りの興味なんですね
自分がもうすごく嫌な人間
自分にとって嫌な人間がいる
それで私はその人の噂を持ってくる
あんたね 何々のさんの何か私は知ってる
よと言ったら 何ですか？あんた興味ある？あるあるある
教えてくれと その時怒りなんですね
逆に欲 何かこういうこと
もうすごい簡単なわかる方法がありますよ
至って簡単だよと 興味あります
教えてくれと その場合を教え
ちゃんと学びます その簡単な方法
簡単な方法を学んでひどくなりますけど
で その欲と怒りがある時でも興味が生まれますけど
それがない興味なんです
あのちっちゃな子供たちはものすごい勢いで学ぶでしょ
ものすごいスピーディーなんですよ
で 男の場合はね 男のズボンの中
ポケットなんか調べると
あるはあるわ いろいろガラクタが入ってるんですよ
もう触らせようともしないし
もうズボン洗ってあげる時でも
気をつけて丁寧にそれ取り出して戻してあげないと
結構機嫌が悪くなるんですね
大人から見れば 石ころやらね
落ちた葉っぱやら 死んだ虫やらね
これポケットに入れて何かいと
あるいは子供の心で この純粋な興味っていうものあるんですよ
あの興味あるんだから
みるみる目の面白くて面白く見えちゃって
後でさらに研究するそうで
ポケットに入れるんです
それから研究するんです
石ころを持って形を見たり
色を見たりして で 並べたりとか
いろいろやってます だから
そういうふうにすごい活発で明るく元気で
もうもうもうもうズボンがいっぱい
ガラクタもゴミばっかりたたんでいる子っていうのは
もうものすごいスピードの方が成長しているんです
で その純粋な興味なんですね
欲でもないし 怒りでもないんです
脳も心も成長したいのです
我々はハンディを持って認知障害を持って生まれたんだけど
成長したいんですよ 脳も成長したくてしたくてもうたまらんですよ
だって原始脳しか配線できてないんだから
大脳に配線できてないんだから
見る 聞く いろんなことで配線しなくちゃあかんですよ
だから大脳が必死なんですよ
学びたくて 新たな情報を取り入れたいという体制でいるんです
しかし 感情がその機能を誘拐するんです
かわいそうで 感情は強烈ですから
生まれる前も生まれる時もありますからね
感情が誘拐するんです
知識の窓口で 怒り 欲などの感情が受付をやっているんです
脳はデータ入れてください
これから学びますと窓口を開けておくんですよ
至るところに 6つですけどね
これもう受付誰でやってるかというと
怒りやら嫉妬やら憎しみやら見栄や傲慢とかね
1500ものあるんだから
この連中を窓口やってるんだから
入れるデータは自分 あの
あの 何て言いますか えっとえっと
不正を働かすね 官僚の人々やら政治家やらね
もう自分のところに国民のお金入れちゃうでしょ
あんな感じで大事に脳に与えるべきデータは
怒りは怒りの形で処分して
感情の刺激に使う 感情を肥やすために使う
欲が窓口にいたら 欲を肥やすために学ぶデータを使う
人格向上に使わないんです
どうですかね 皆様の窓口の受付は誰がやってますかね
客観的なデータが入らなくなります
もう着服されちゃってるんで
原始脳に 真理を知りたい
新たなことを知りたい
成長したい 性格を改良したいなどの純粋な興味を抱くんです
すごい簡単です この喜びを感じることは
ただ これを覚えておいてください
真理を知りたい 本当のことを知りたいよと
あるいは成長したいんだと
もっと真面目な人間になりたいんだと
性格は改良したいんだと
それくらい簡単でしょ
まあ改良したいんだ 性格はね
こういうだらしない性格を本当にもう
もうしょうがない どうしようもない
直さなくちゃ そこを入れちゃうと窓口が OK です
目的変えたんだからね
もう感情 ではなくなっちゃうんです
で 考えるほど難しくないんです
新たなデータが入って
理解能力が上がると 心は喜びを感じます
今度 原始脳じゃないんです
古い脳じゃないんです
成長したがっている大脳
成長したいなと窓口に受付入れたら
あの いわゆる進歩したいというね
気持ちを入れておく 窓口で
そこの窓口ですからね
で そうするとデータがちゃんと大脳に入る
大脳がそれちゃんと分析する
分析して あ あれ あ こういうことかと
なんかわかる で びっくりする
この研究する科学者も
何か新たなものを発見したら
えらい感動するんですよ
もう楽しくてたまらなくなっちゃうんですよ
興奮しちゃうんです あるいは
まあ原始脳も関わっているかもしれませんだけど
ほぼ大脳なんです あの喜びを感じるのは
だから 何か新しいものを学んだら
なんかやけに楽しくなっちゃうんですよ
あの楽しみなんです こちらで推薦しているのは
これは欲が作る喜びと怒りが作る刺激と違うものです
あの欲が出てくると力がなくなるんですね
疲れるんですよ だから脳も疲れる
体力も体も疲れる 怒りが出てくると
瞬発的に力が出るんだけど
全部焼けてるんです それで終わり
しかし 正しい喜びはそうじゃないんです
あれはすごくこの うーん
なんていいます 成長させるんですよ
栄養になるんです 栄養剤なんです
だから大脳が喜びを感じると
これは体も元気 疲れません
もっと勉強したくなる
もっと調べたくなる 脳も疲れません
正しい喜びが起こるならば
心は際限なく成長します
成長にはリミットがない
まあありますけど 解脱に達するというよね
で 際限なく成長します
本当に私たちはどれほど損しているのかと
理解できますかね 怒りで
嫉妬で勉強して 例えば 100キロ走るぐらい体力ある人が
1キロ走ったところでこけて怪我して倒れるような感じでしょ
これもったいないでしょ
100億円儲かる能力ある人が
朝から晩まで頑張って 1
日1万ぐらい儲かるんだと
もったいないでしょ  100億円儲かるということは
別な事業に手を出さなくちゃあかんでしょ
それしないでマクドナルドでバイトやっている
そうやっちゃうと いくら経営能力あったっても
マクドナルドではそれは成長しません
そういうふうに私たちはものすごいこの知識という宝物
だからお釈迦様のスローガンですよ
私も自分のスローガンでも使ってますけど
パンニャーナラーナンラタナンチエは人間にとっては宝物であると
本物の宝物ですよ だからそれあるにも関わらず
この欲 怒り 嫉妬の感情のハンディに負けて
私は障害者だからしょうがないでしょうという
まあすごく気持ち悪い言い方をしているんです
障害者だからってしょうがないじゃないんです
障害を克服しなさいなんです
そういうことで 興味という一言
葉 全然わからないんだったら
子供たちを観察してください
何にも興味ある 中学生はダメです
幼稚園で 1 年生までです
それからもう立派な世界はね
壊すんです 脳は成長しないように
怒り 嫉妬 嫉妬 傲慢 見栄も叩き込むんです
叩き込む必要ない もともと持っているんだからね
ちょっとしたことでもこれが強化します
だから小 1 から以下の子供たちを見てください
何にも興味あると言ったって
何もろくにもやらないしね
でも興味だけはある それで勢いで脳は成長するし
ものすごい体力もあって元気なんです
はい これで今日のお話は終わりますけど
続けて あの だから法を聞く
法を学ぶ時 純粋な興味だけ持ち持ってくださいと
それだけです 皆様 カーラム経典はもうとっくに知っていると思います
講演 3つ  4つぐらいやりましたからね
お釈迦様が慈悲を あなたは自分で考えなさいよと言いながら説法しているんです
説法を聞く方法といっても
一方的に聞いてくださいはないんです
だから自分で考えるために
自分で質問するために
自分が興味を持たなくちゃあかんでしょ
だから喜びを持って法を聞きなさいというのは
もうありがたく土下座させて
ブッダを私は信じます
教えは信じますという
あのけしからんな態度じゃないんです
あんなの気持ち悪いんです
理解もしていないくせに信じますとか
興味だけ持てばいいんです
教えて教えて 本当にどうなってどうなっているとかね
あ そうですか そうですかとかね
そういう感じで 私も純粋興味生まれて
私に聞いちゃうとすぐ教えますよ
時間も関係なく 場所も関係なく
私は旅をしたかもしれませんだけど
それはやめちゃってる
でもその時は教えるんです
時々もう教える時間なのに
まずあっち向く場合もあります
それはもう向こうのバイアスの問題なんです
だから何のことなく教えて教えて
どうなってる？これは
これどうなってる？というね
その明るさだけです そんな難しいことじゃないんです
はい そういうことでもうちょっと付属的なことをグラジュアルプログレスというね
成長は順次に起こるものということでね
当たり前です 順次に人は成長していく
中部経典の 70 番目 キータディスッタというんです
以上の経典の一段落を紹介します
一段落で言ったってのは半分だけ
段落の ナーハンビッカラエ アディケーネーヴァ アニャーラーダナン ワダーミ アピチャ ビッカラ
エ アヌプッバ シッカーアヌプッバ キリア アヌプッバ パティパダ アニャーラーダナ ホーティ
これを我々仏教を学ぶ場合はすごい大事なフレーズとして学ぶんです
暗記するんです 私は突然
訳ちょっとわかりません
突然 あるいは初めから
アーディケーネーヴァっていうのは
アットザベリービギニングファンダメンタルということですから
この突然という意味がよろしいと思いますけど
初めからね 智慧が現れると言いません
まあ説法を聞いて はい
智慧が現れた はい 悟りまった
それはないよと 順次に学んで
順次に努力して 順次に実践して智慧に達するんですと
だから焦らなくても落ち込まなくてもいいんです
順次に頑張ればいいんです
それで智慧が現れる次第の道
サッダージャータ ウパサンカメティ
ウパサンカ ミャンマー語がウパサンカマント
我々はウパサンカントと言いますけど
ウパサンカマント パイリパーサティ
信 サッダートの信 信仰の信ですね
これを信頼というふうに理解してください
信頼が生じたら伺います
ということは 師匠を伺って付き合ってみるんです
まず あ あの人なら信頼できそう
あの人なら頭が良さそうという
まだ証拠足らないんですね
だから信と言うんですね
あの人こそ唯一の師匠であると言えないんです
なんか人気もあるし よく名前を知られているし
みんなあの人のところで学ぶし
有名な知識人も学んでいるし
もしかすると信頼できるでしょう程度でいいんです
信仰は それでいきなり学ぶんじゃなくて
付き合う です 皆様の場合はこの付き合い方下手で逆効果になるんですけどね
あの 教えてもらいたい人に自由を侵そうとしているんですね
私は一人でいるの そういうわけなんですね
私は教えてあげる側だからね
私にいちいち言うんじゃないんです
あんたこうしなさい ああしなさいって
それは付き合いじゃないんですね
そうすると あんた帰ってくれませんかと
もう教えてもらうことはできなくなるんです
目上の人と付き合うっていうことは
ただ付き合うだけなんです
何も別に大したことやらなくてもいいんです
ただ単にこの付き合いを運びたいんだけど
あんたこちらから取る
はい わかりました それで十分です
あるいはこれ 私一人で運べますから
どこでおけばいい？そんな感じで師匠を管理しようとしないで付き合ってみる
師匠が料理しているんだったら
まあ邪魔にならないように
ちょっとまあなんて言いますか
お手伝いするとかね で
そうなってくると 師匠の師匠の性格が見えてくる
師匠の心にああ こいつは性格がいい
傲慢ではありません ちゃんとその日常のことをちゃんと判断するとわかったところで
料理しながら歯を磨きながらも掃除しながらもいろんなことを
実はね これはこういうことだよとか
ただ会話的に話が始まるんです
で そういうふうな学び方ですけどね
パイルパーさんと総探訪だはて
そこで付き合っているうちに
耳を傾ける 傾けることになる
話を聞いてみる気持ちが通じるんです
どんどん だからブッダはいきなり私の話を聞けでもないんです
まずちょこっとあの裏データ調べてね
裏付けとか何とかね 調べて信頼できるかないかと
信頼できたらもうちょっと付き合ってみなさいよと
付き合ってみると じゃあこの人の話聞いたってもいいんじゃない？って聞く気持ちになります
おひと相当ダンマンスナーで耳を傾けたら
話を聞く気になったら
法真理を聞くんです スットアダンマンダーレーティ法を聞いて覚えるんです
これがすごい大事 現代人にはないんです
あの紙が覚えているんだからね
IC レコーダーが覚えているんだから
あれは勉強にならないんです
だって人格向上でしょ？思考の発展でしょ
判断能力を育む 改良することでしょ
脳の仕事でしょ だから海馬を使ってほしいんです
この海馬っていうのは古い脳にあるんですよ
古い脳に感情を作っている場合じゃないんです
仕事はあるんです データを覚えておきなさいとかね
だから学んだことを覚えることってものすごい大事なんです
私も成功成長したのは覚えたものなんです
あの研究して書いたものっていうのは
もうあの二十歳頃でもこれぐらい厚い分厚い長くあったんですよ
で 研究して 調べて調べて
書くか 書いて書いて書いて書いて大量に論文を書くんです
書いては溜まっておく
時々びっくりする私 あれ？誰がここまで研究した？俺でしたっけ？と
そう 忘れているんです
しかし 経典の中でいろいろものは頭で覚えておくんです
覚えたものが心の中で反応して人格を変えていくんです
だから覚えるということが必要です
ダターナンダンマーナンアッタンウパパリッカティスディ
覚えた法の意味を観察考察する
例えば我々はそれをよくやりますよ
でなきゃ説法できません
例えば前言ったお釈迦様が使っていたモットーというか
スローガン 智慧は人間にとって宝物であると
で 私は覚えているんですね
パンニャーナラーナンラタナン
で 次 パンニャーナラーナンラタナン
智慧は宝物でありって何でしょうかね
これはと これはまず事実
お釈迦様に説かれたんだから
でも俺はわからない これは
事実なのに それでいろんなところを考えたり考察したりすると
ああ なるほど 智慧がなければ人間と猿は同じでしょうにと
人間人間たれしめることは
いくらなんでも間違いながらでも智慧でしょうにと
やっぱりすべての宝 俗世間的な宝物も智慧からもらう二次的な財産であると
だから本物の宝物は智慧であるというふうに理解していくんですよ
覚えていないとできないんです
アッタン ウパーリッケトー ダンマ ダンマー ニッジャーナン カマンティ
意味を考察すると 法に対して納得が生じる
これ大事です ああ そうかいと
ああ そういうことでしたかと
わかったと この普通わかったということは
納得いったって これ心の中に何か変化が起きちゃったんですよ
何かひらめきが起きたんです
ひらめいたということは
新しい神経が新しい電気を
電波を出して回路を作っちゃったんです
神経細胞がつながっちゃったんです
ダンマ ニッジャーナ カンティア サティ チャンドー ジャーエティ
法に納得したならば 意欲が生じるんです
順番でしょ 納得したら
やっぱりわかった これですかと
ああ ではやった方がいいと
そこで意欲が生じるんです
チャンダ ジャートー ウッサーハティ
意欲が生じたら精進する
ウッサーヘットワ トゥレーティ
精進しては比較してみる
これ科学的な研究みたいなもんだから
いくらか精進してやってみて
結果見る どうなったんですかねとかね
ああ こうなってる こうなってると
しかしここここ辺はダメやとかね
これで比較してみるんですね
トゥレーティワ パダヘティ
また比較しては比較してはさらに励む
精進しては比較する 比較してはさらに励むという
着々と進んでいくんです
パヒタットー サマーナ カーエーヌ チエワ パラモン サッチャン サッチガローティ
励んでゆくと 最初の真理を体験する
で カーエーナチェーワっていうのは体でもいわゆる脳の変化なんですね
体でいう場合は 脳がもう心理の回路を作っちゃって
体が変わるんです 体が変わったっていうことは
脳だけじゃなくて神経システム全部変わるんです
デンタスシステムが それはお釈迦様の時代では脳科学がなかったんだから
お釈迦様はいたって簡単で
体で感じると これを日本語で言えば体験するということになるんです
それで 脳細胞だけじゃなくて心ありますからね
心に変化を起こります
それは智慧と言うんです
智慧で物事を見られるようになる
体に変化が起きても それが解脱ということはちょっと言いづらいんですね
体と心が一緒で繋がっていますから
同時に智慧でも心に智慧が現れるんです
体に智慧が現れないんです
心に智慧が現れて 解脱は完了する
アティヴィッジョパッサティとは
超越した次元で物事を見られることです
こちらのアティヴィッジョパッサティってありますね
これは超越した鋭い智慧で見られるということですね
で 普通 仏教用語で如実に見るという言葉を使っているんですね
これは俗世間の人々の見方ではなくて
脳は脳を開発した人々の見方なんですね
人 師匠を信頼して聞く耳を持って法を聞かなかったら何も起こらないと
経典のこの段落は終了します
だからお釈迦様がこのある人が
あるアホが完全なる悟りに達するんですよ
障害者だからみんな あの認知障害者が完全なる悟りに達していると
しかし どうやってこれ道を始めたんですかね
まず師匠を信頼して聞く耳を持った
この順番 だから まず裏のいろいろデータを調べて
人は信頼できるかないかと
信頼できそうだなだったら
さらに付き合ってみて
OK と だったら話を聞くと
そこからすべて始まるんです
だからブッダの世界は聞くことから始まるんです
漫画本からではないんです
漫画でブッダの生涯とかね
ブッダの話 漫画でいくら読んでもくっだらない意味になるだけで
決して優れたものにはならない
書けません 後で衰退した仏教では
この聴聞というのはね
本当に優れていない だらしない道であると言ってますけど
あれは相当衰退した仏教の方々が言っていることなんですね
心理学的に言えば やっぱり聞く
このチャネルで悟りに達する道が始まるんです
別に聴聞で悟れるわけじゃないんです
そこで道がスタートするんです
はい まあこんなもんではないかなと思います
話は 門戸は解脱の門を開く
鵜呑みにしないで 感情に負けないで
客観的に調べて 自分自身で判断して
自分で成長の過程を比較して
怠ることなく励むことで真理を発見する
人格は完成する で終わりでしょ
一応それで終わり はい
そういうことで  そのように話を基本です
以上で どうもありがとうございます
えっと 今日興味という話がありましたけれども
お話がありましたけれども
瞑想するときもそういう姿勢でやるといいんでしょうか
えっと 何をしてもちょっと成長したければ興味が必要なんですね
でなきゃ進まないんですよ
山を登る時でも やっぱり上に行きたいなとかね
気持ちが必要なんですね
何だろうかなとかね 興味が必要なんですね
だから瞑想する時 みんな失敗するのは
この こういうことを経験したい
こういうことを経験したと
この先を妄想しちゃうでしょ
あれがもう科学的でなく
絶対やってはいけないんですね
どうなることやと 今今の自分の瞑想実践に対して興味を持つ
この興味っていうのは
私はキュウリオシティっていう言葉
英語で言葉を書けたんだけど
もう一つ皆様知ってる日本語の英語の単語がありますね
Interest あの利子ではありません
その interest はよく知っていると思いますけど
あの interest interesting とかね
それが必要なんですよ
でないと体動かないんです
必要だと思います はい
ありがとうございました
えっと 耳からその法を聞くのが一番いい聞き方だとおっしゃると思いますが
先生の出していらっしゃるこのブッダの実践心理学というのは
この紙媒体以外に何かオーディオブックとかになってますか？ うーん
ちょっとわからない  あの耳から
耳から あ あのね 本を読むこと
耳からなんです あ そうですね
説明しましたでしょ はい
本を読むことと漫画を読むこと違いますから
本を読むと視覚はそんなに働いてないんです
頭で喋ってるんです でしょ？本を読む時は
本を読むということは
頭でその言語を喋っているんです
だからそれは耳からのチャンネルなんです
脳の中で耳のチャンネルを使っているんです
だから大丈夫です  活字であれば OK だと
そうそう  わかりました
ありがとうございます
よろしくお願いします
実は私 初めてこの会に参加
この会というか こちらの仏教にのお話を聞かせていただくんですけども
実は別の形で心理学というものを学んでいるんですね
ただ 私も周りの人たちを幸せにしたいと思って
その心理学を学び始めたんですが
一向に理解ができないんですけど
その理由もわからないんです
それは一体どうしてでしょうか？ だから
あの普通の心理学っていうのは
それほど優れたものじゃないんですよ
あれは人間の病気とかね
人間失敗したところとかね
見ながらいろいろ試行錯誤でやってるものだから
あのちょっと研究者もわからないし
科学者もよくわからないし
また魂論とかいろんなことをもう変な概念を割り込んでいるしね
それから人間どうするべきかということもよくわかってないでしょ
どうなればいいかということもないでしょ
だからずっと曖昧なんですね
そういう結構現代心理学にはたくさんハンディはあります
仏教心理学は人間は成長するべき
このままではダメという立場から始まるんですね
だから人間にとって問題は何かとちゃんと分析して
これをどうやって解決するのかということもちゃんと解決して分析してあげてますね
だから 人間の精神的な問題っていうのは
もう至って簡単に仏教の方では治るようにはしますけど
しかし 仏教はこの精神的な病んでいる人々を治る仕事ではなくて
人間をね 超越させるための世界
ですから そこは専門的にやりません
まああの...やっぱり生きるって何なのかっていうことをね
ちょっと考えておかないと
まあそちらの質問された方にもわからなくなると思いますよ
だからそれ調べるとまた壁にぶつかると思いますよ
その時仏教の話を聞いてください
生きることはこういうことだとちゃんと明確に説明してやります
で それをわかってからは
まあ即席の知識もうまく使えます
そういうふうに まあいろいろ学んで心を広げてみてください
今日いい話をした人は本当によくわかるんですが
ちょっとあの コメントしていただきたいのはですね
よくまあ嫉妬とか欲っていうのは良くない
人間の形成には良くないと言われるんですが
一方 それをバネにしていい仕事をする人はという考え方もありますね
それと 先生が言われるこの人格的成長
属的な成長と こう 2つあると思うんですが
そこら辺について少しコメントをいただけるとありがたいんですが
あの世間ではそう思ってます
で まあデータ的にもものすごく嫉妬で燃えて
怒りで燃えて 競争心で燃えて頑張ってる人もいますよ
しかし 私から言えば寒いんだから
家の家具やら全部壊して燃やすような感じなんですよ
確かにあったかいんですよ
冬 家にある家具やら毛布やらね
布団やら全部火をつけて
わっしゃあったかいんですよ
問題は解決したんだけど
それでいいのを解決ですね
だから我々は生命力を成長するんじゃなくて
もうもう燃やしちゃうんですね
生命力っていうのは際限なく生まれてほしいんです
だから仏教が言ってるのは
このすぐエネルギー切れで燃や燃え尽きちゃ尽きる生き方じゃないんです
際限なくエネルギーが生まれてきて
いつでも元気で明るくている方法なんですね
それでちょっとある例があって言っていいのかないかわからないんだけど
ある人は私にこのちっちゃな本を出して
これちょっと読んでみてくれませんかと
なんか間違いあったら言ってくださいと
何かと見たら 本人の博士論文なんですね
で 見ただけで私は却下なんですけど
これは言えないんだからね
私は あのね 私はもう学者の世界から離れてね
かなり時間経ってますと
だからもう読みたくもないんだと
で 批判もしたくはないんだと
だからいまだに現役でやっている誰かに読んでもらったらどうでしょうかと
あんた読んだらとかね
言ったら私の批判っていうのは結構きついですよと言ったんです
言っても批判しなかったんです
なぜか ではそこまで言うならばといって
全部もう見たら 私は思ったのはね
これだったら私は学部
学部論文だったらOK出しますよという気持ちなんです
修士課程の論文として持ってきたら追い出しますよと
でも本人には言わなかったんです
それでどう言えばいいかといって
困って困って あのね まあちょっと読んだ
見たところで ちょっと理論があまり美しく成り立ってない
まあちゃんと分析して正しく分析していない
データをしっかり整理していないとかね
そういうところを見てたら
言葉違いだと 使っている英語でしたけど
あんた使ってる英語っていうのは
一般的に使う まあ日常的に普通のもう 3 3流の記事なんか書く英語だと
この英語で論文書きませんと
だからもう一度このアカデミックイングリッシュで書き直してくださいと
そうなってくると 我々にとってもさっと読めますよと
もう最低英語だけでも書き直してよと言ってやめたんですね
しかし その人はなんで情けない価値のないことを苦労して書くのかというと
気持ちすごい苦労していることは見える
しかし 正しくデータを扱っていないし
調べていない 調べるべきものはまだたくさんある
そのテーマでは なぜかと本人書いているテーマについて
私にはこんな感じで もう 2 3時間ざーっと喋れます
そのまま書けば論文になります
本人調べていない それで私は悲しくなったのは
この人 すごく見栄で博士取ったぞという一般人に見栄張りたいだけなんですね
博士っていうのは学者的なもので
学者の間で研究者の間で認めなくちゃあかんけど
一般人に何に博士と言われたっても
アホが面白がるんだけど
本物の博士にとってはどうったことないんです
だから その例で私が何を感じたかで
やっぱり見栄っていうのは相当人に苦労させますよと
だから見栄がなく 研究する興味だけ
新たなポイントを出し出しましょうよというね
そういう学問的な興味
インタレストだけ持った方が淡々と楽々にエネルギーが出てくるでしょ
どんな本でも調べたくなるし
もうすごい元気になるんですね
だからこの会社の場合は
これ 学校の場合でも この怒りとかね
嫉妬とかね 入れちゃってかわいそうやと思いますよ
結果ないとは思いませんよ
でもあれはもう残念な結果で
1億円儲けるのに 101万円儲かったんじゃないかっていう話なんですよ
だから 嫉妬で何か成果出す人が嫉妬抜きにして
柔らかな心でやると それよりは 1万倍結果が出ます
だから結果出す出しますけど
もったいないんですよ
だから感情にはさようならと言って
慈しみで生きた方がものすごい万々歳なんです
いくらでも力ある いくらでも能力ある
いくらでも頭が冴えてくる
衰退はしない あの お経の偈で教えたでしょ
衰退するんですね だから私の例えで言えば
家にある家具やらもう燃えるものを全部拾ってきて燃やしちゃって
冬を越そうと思ったような感じなんです
冬は長いんですよ 家に燃えるものでは 1日2日なんとかなるかもしれませんだけど
家が火事にならなかったら
冬は長いんです それが道じゃないんです
そういうわけで 私のコメントは
決して怒り 嫉妬 競争心などは
人間にとっては俗世間的にも成長するために使うべき衝動ではありませんということです
ありがとうございました
はい ちょうど時間になりましたので
これで終了したいと思います
皆さんは最後に回向の文をお唱えして終了したいと思いますので
合掌してください  回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に来拝帰依し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
...はい ありがとうございます
どうも  これにて初期仏教公開講座日本テーラワーダ仏教協会の月例講演会を終了させていただきます
[終楽]